all right now more despicable smear
tactics from the far left tonight as the
salt lake tribune ran an editorial
cartoon comparing
african-american republican congressmen
from the fourth district in utah
burgess owens get this to the ku klux
klan now the cartoon is disgusting
beyond reprehensible but unfortunately
it's the type of repugnant behavior we
have seen way too often from the mob and
the media
and by the way the media never really
covered the story about
joe biden praising and eulogizing
the former member of the kkk robert byrd
even working with the former klansmen to
stop the integration of our schools
because joe said he didn't want our
schools to become
racial jungles is the media ever going
to cover that
salt lake tribute never cover that here
with reaction republican congressman
the fourth district of utah burgess
owens you know
burgess we become very good friends
you're often on my radio show
i think the world of you uh i want an
apology and i want a retraction from the
salt lake city tribute
what are your words i don't want to put
words in your mouth this this was
despicable
to me yeah well first of all don't
expect any apology uh one thing about
racists they're they're
they're very cocky about the way they
feel they think their worldview is
shared by everybody let me just say this
real quick i grew up in the deep south
in the 60s
and at the age of 16 i was just getting
a chance to be introduced to white
americans i came to a conclusion
of what racist racism looked like there
was a southern and a northern southern
were people who hated black community
but at least you knew it they knew you
knew what they stood for
you knew they would try to uh delete you
damage you or hurt you whenever they
could and then there's a northern one
which i now call elitist
these are the ones that uh they smile on
your face they say they love you they
put their arms around you and they stab
you
back as soon as you they find out that
that you don't agree with what they
think
they think black people could think uh
should be thinking these people
the racist trib could care less about
black people they can care less about
the hispanics those victims coming
across the border which is what i was
talking about these kids
they have an agenda and what they want
to do is divide us they wanted their
bullies and cowards
they uh they hide behind a newspaper so
complicit
and they attack uh they hide behind good
hearted democrats
and they attack uh and it's time for us
to call these people out and
let americans know you'll you're not
what these these racists think
you are they're projecting exactly who
they are
okay so i know you as a man of deep
faith
incredible impeccable character um
a strong community leader in so many
ways your entire life and career you
live by example
is there anything you can do legally
have you spoken to any lawyers
no i and i don't plan on going that
direction uh i i want the american
people just to know
uh in particular utahns uh utahns don't
don't take uh this
idea that they have decided to double
down that you they represent utah
these people are outliers uh they they
did the same thing to mia love
they did the same thing to police as as
black lives matters were killing
uh were there the blacks dying all last
summer 24 of them
hundreds of black business being uh
burned down uh and they were applauding
this rioting uh and then and then they
uh they call out our police
kkk members so no the american people
will take care of this
i believe in free market and i think
that we're going to turn off and tune
off
to racism no matter where it comes from
including those who
wrap themselves in compassion but at the
same time
show that they really could care less
about my my great race
okay do you think it's racist
no question no question listen i grew up
around it
i grew up i know exactly racism looks
like no matter how shuttled they are at
the end of the day
um they would not treat any by any of
the of my delegates my
my other friends this way and they would
not keep they would not uh
treat them their other white friends
this way no they want to destroy
uh the the the idea of black independent
people
uh those who reach the middle class
those who do not need them and they will
destroy us in any way they can and it's
not gonna happen
in this country we're gonna overcome
this and we're gonna see this see them
for who they are and
move on all right keep doing the great
job you're doing we appreciate it
burgess owens